microsoft just wrapped up its press
conference at Gamescom to kick things
off and Danny onto our you just got to
play forza motorsport six votes I'm on
the south side hey man we've been in
gamescom we've been here in Cologne
beautiful Germany ever you know 12 hours
so you know what's been the debate the
most impressive thing I've seen since I
got here Gilman nope oh so puddles all
the puddles outside are 15 we're totally
drenched we've all got umbrellas and it
turns out Forza Motorsport six has been
inspired by quick gamescom I had some
sick puddles in it yo if that was the
focus of the entire presentation for the
game and I'm wondering if someone who's
played the series for years I mean is
this something you've been waiting for
Lee does it feel like this is worth a
new iteration a new full reason being i
loved racing games i love playing a
variety of racing games out of f 1 i'm
playing loads of project cars and I like
the courts of games as well and rain has
always been like involved in racing game
but it's generally been this kind of
okay the track is wet which means you've
got nice grip yeah and then that sort of
had this sort of like even change to
everything in the car to Griffin's are
like how hot tires get all that feels
like a binary switch it wasn't really
knew exactly it wasn't like there were
certain parts of the track that had more
water what you might call a puddle well
reports of motorsport 6 are poets huh
motorsport six man it's got follows and
when Dan Greenawalt gets off on the
stage starts talking about puddles it's
easy to be like pretty flippin to bed
you know sure for God's sake they're
just puddles it's actually pretty great
okay but let me play double bass okay is
this not something that could just be
added to force 1s 45 as DLC mean there's
got to be more to this than just puddles
right well they've got a bunch more cars
got a bunch more circuit today I think
that can be done with DLC let's chat hey
but we kill them to conversation about
fifa and madden we call a duty would be
here all day long and the one thing i
will say is that it is definitely
something new i am experiencing in a
driving day so i was thinkin brian at
brands hatch so i'm driving up like one
of those they're like easier corners in
the dryer right you sort of you come out
of a sharp left-hander and it's uphill
and it's like a little crested right and
you can generally like dry tries we can
hit it real fast again here over the top
but there's this model that's
accumulated on the side of the road
right and when you drop ram into it a
full speed even like the driving i will
tell you slow down here it like pulls
one side of the car and this is
interesting for two reasons one because
it makes you not maybe like take time
with that corner bit too and also maybe
makes you be big got see if you're gonna
slow lap maybe we'll just push into it
and try and correct it on the other side
but perhaps the most interesting part of
it is what they when you come out of a
corner there are some corners in circuit
seafood tonight of dirty because you
know we haven't got a really tough
corner coming up for a while so you can
kind of like mess up the gear and like
you have the box wiggling out of it if
there's a puddle on my corner and your
back is going it's gonna like
overemphasize not even more so that's
what happened to me I went off the top I
turn this corner I was kind of losing
the back in a bit and I saw it I was
like I'll be fine and I hit this thing
puddles man into the barrier hit rewind
take a little bit better on that corner
turns out bubbles may be a better driver
region it again huggles i like it i hope
i hope they have wet rain for as many
tracks as possible and obviously I'm
excited to form an e car is going to be
in at this year's game while hopping I'm
translating yet these are pretty
exciting as a bunch more tracks
circuited Americans in this year's game
and Sonoma Raceway which was really read
in the Bay Area and Monza is also been
added as well so there's you know more
trucks more cars more photos more Forza
more important all right stay tuned to
more coverage for games come gamespot
com